[Music]
will eminems still melt in your hands if
they identify as trans
when i eat a bag of m ms do i wonder
which color and shape best represents my
identity no because it's chocolate and
also it's obviously the orange one
but the iconic candy company is giving
the mascots makeovers to make them more
inclusive how are they doing this well
obviously by changing their footwear
instead of go-go boots the seductress
green eminem will now wear sneakers
additionally their voices will be
updated in a tone that's more welcoming
sorry cat no voiceovers for you
said catherine slight interesting chief
growth officer at mars wrigley
who better to commit to a world with
more moments of fun by increasing a
sense of belonging around the globe
than eminem's i don't know maybe three
musketeers we could replace their swords
with protest signs but honestly this is
weird if you really truly want to make
an m m feel like they belong
you probably shouldn't be eating them
i mean what kind of message does it send
to children when you devour these little
non-binary bond bonds
for commentary we go to our candy
correspondence
that was not a candy correspondent
cat yes okay
they want to make their little
characters inclusive and then you're
going to eat them no no i have so many
thoughts on this yes i do the green
eminem is a snake yes the new one the
new one okay listen the little they have
little statements and she says
i think we all win when we see more
women in leading roles so i'm happy to
take on the part of supportive friend
when they succeed okay like none of you
guys are women but women all know that
the women are like i'm a woman and i'm
pro-woman and they're called pro-women i
am you can't trust them because real
women they just do it they don't need to
brag about it like they're running some
kind of campaign and she admits she's
doing that she says the port of a
supportive friend when they succeed
right like okay yeah i bet you want to
be you know their friend when they
succeed like you conniving climbing
little [ __ ] i do not trust her all
right i don't want to be her friend so
she somehow made it worse that's that's
the worst cut you need to run from women
like the green eminem the new green
animal yes the green eminem is an uh is
disgusting opportunistic evil [ __ ] wow
wow
you know uh rob i have to say this is
that corporations may be the most
embarrassing entity in all of wokedom
right because they're so obvious about
like trying to create a distraction
please don't come after us for our
diabetic starter kit which is what candy
is right you know here we look at what
we did to our little characters but
don't look at all the problems sugar
causes yeah don't look at the
co-morbidity you're creating yes um i
was interested though cat is projecting
a lot into the green eminem i feel like
we should not we really should come back
to that at some point maybe the next
session i'm not projecting i'm
reflecting on my own experience yeah no
m's are kind of the progressives idea of
the future of the human being right
we're all kind of shiny and a different
color and we have no genitalia um that's
kind of where they want us to go
and if you put them in your mouth the
color comes off i don't know what that
means
this is part of this weird thing jesse
where we have to make sure on seven
billion people in the planet not a
single person can have their feelings
hurt so they everybody's got to do
something to make sure everybody's okay
i'm going to try my hand at comedy again
oh god and hope it works this time
i came up with some offensive candies oh
god i think we need to change their
branding
butter finger oh yeah oh yeah but his
finger oh very good
good good hershey's kisses
hershey's consensual kisses nice very
good
jolly rancher
jolly sustainable rancher
so i just stopped there you've really
enjoyed that that's good
all right you know i'm gonna save some
for the five yeah which we already taped
yeah you did a great job by the way i
would say um
[Music]
butterfinger it's butt their finger
that's my only my only note thank you
dan you can fit more than one
last word to you walter
so this is all fake yeah m m's were
already woke right a bowl of rainbow
colored candies is as woke as it gets
yeah that's true but they wanted to get
the pr for going woke so they had to
invent a problem they had to invent a
confession oh we aren't as woke as we
can be and so
this is fake
number two
where's skittles
yeah is skittles just gonna stay
racist and you know
because that will give america a choice
yeah exactly exactly yeah um
yes you got a number three i had my wife
write all my bits because she knew i
would be taking these painkillers
and uh thanks girl i think that i think
we
we got to do a special gut felt episode
where we are all on painkillers
if we announce it beforehand then it's
not a problem right just research yeah
research we could call it the cnn new
year's eve special personally first we
all have to break a finger though so we
can get a prescription
butt their finger
yeah up next tips for jesse so his debut
show isn't messy
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else